greetings from podcast Ville it's
Tuesday January 20 something who gives a
[ __ ] it's your day to get up there and
get out there and let these
[ __ ] know who they're dealing
with the church is brought to you by
stamps calm listen to me you want a new
year's resolution that actually you can
keep stop wasting your time going to the
post office when you could send letters
and packages right from your desk at
home do it today with stamps.com
listen I've been using stamps calm my
wife and I for the last five or six
years that's how we send our t-shirt top
that's we turn the mugs out they are
tremendous do you understand me if
you're not on stamps calm it's a
no-brainer you're not saving time so
what I'm gonna do is this you could use
stamps calm because so no brain it saves
time and money right now they got a
special offer what they gonna do is give
you a four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale to start your new year off
right
get your trial today do me a favor go to
stamps comm and click at the microphone
at the top of the homepage and use promo
code church that stamps.com
and enter promo code Church and start
sending mail like a doctor with
stamps.com also I want to welcome to the
church one of my personal favorites
zip recruiter why because it's how you
hire people that's smart you want the
right people applying for your job you
know what's not smart job boards that
send you candidates aren't qualified for
the road you posted you know what's not
smart job boards that say you're my
stack of resumes to sort through but you
know what is smart going to zip
recruiter comm slash Church again that
zip recruiter comm slash Church to hire
the right person and right now the
church family could try zip recruiter
for free you hear what I just said free
free free free by going to zip recruiter
comm slash Church if you love the show
and you want to show support do me a
favor I don't care how big or small your
business is going to zip recruiter
dot-com slash church that zip recruit
calm
slash church are smarter way to hire
take this [ __ ] melee what's happening
you bad [ __ ] I hope you enjoyed
the weekend I hope everything is all
right we got my man Jake Ellenberger
here part 2 part 1 he smoked a reefer
debt and he didn't remember where he was
how did you feel dawg I felt like I was
like I was like oh DeMaio I was talking
to Patrick Swayze I was [ __ ] I was on
a look like he was getting higher in the
iron just to clear the air there was no
edibles involved it was one bong hit
and what people don't realize is that
the [ __ ] I'm getting now is like a bunch
of white chemists getting again start
these little geeky guys getting together
and every day they try to make it one
more percentage stronger and I'm dead
guinea pig and if I'm their guinea pig
and you smoke with me let's say you're
their guinea pig
yeah well one of my so the 80s then when
a significant gain mice that's the same
thing we're the same thing with smoking
heavy duty on it getting [ __ ] up to
the gills and now that I don't do that
much other bulls like I hate to little
things last night I slept like a baby
mm-hmm cuz I gotta pay it when you don't
eat edibles you sleep those two [ __ ] at
least for me I go right back to where I
was
inconsistencies when I eat edibles I
sleep like a [ __ ] baby I sleep like a
baby when you wake up there's no
hangover sometimes there's a little bit
of a hangover but you take a [ __ ] you
drink some coffee your bong it in your
back like you balanced all your chakras
are open you're ready to take the day by
the balls and spit in its face see them
saying there's something about your weed
to that it has a time delay release like
I think that's what was Jake was fine
yeah Jake what's fine fine yeah whatever
they're doing at the plant or what I
like it's it's delay release it's crazy
and it gets worse and worse
listen I can't do on a Sunday one day
just to clear the air with people ever
since I got the edibles out I'm getting
higher and higher
sometimes you gotta hear me at midnight
Lee how high do I sound at midnight
someplace oh my I don't think you
remember talking to sometimes
ice
swear to God I get back from doing
comedy and I go in that bathroom and
this times I'm magnificent and I fell
that pipe up three or four times I'm
like what am I doing with my life
yeah and then I'll go out and I'll put
music on and I'll just sit there and
stare at my daughter's drawings I'm like
what [ __ ] and I'll call me and I'll
forget because what happens is this
really happens before I go onstage
I get so much [ __ ] anxiety well I'm
taking a shower to go onstage at the
Comedy Store I get so much [ __ ]
anxiety
so as I walked out I take one of those
0.25 little [ __ ] xanaxes that they give
you the anxiety pills and I put them in
my top pocket this is what happens to me
I go down to the store and I said I walk
in the store the anxiety starts hitting
me so I pop one of those pills and then
I go to the original room I go onstage
and I'm fine and I don't feel the
effects of the pill and nothing till I
start driving up to hell so watch my
adrenaline goes down the pill picks up I
figured it out like well this is the
only thing that could be affecting me I
don't drink alcohol
but there's nights after high quality my
speech slurs like there's night I get
that stone you don't slur with me just
sound really really tired I'm like why
is he so tired it's because I've done
eight [ __ ] pipe full of weed by
myself in a bathroom with the locks
closed and I got no a ventilation in
that I won't open up the dog is a
raccoon back there
I gotta fight a [ __ ] rat wait yeah I
sit there like a Jew in Auschwitz by
myself getting the steam to depth and I
just sit there in that room and I smoke
and I opened the door and I have to
close it real quick so the wheat smart
doesn't go in the house bro so therefore
my daughter's birthday I had to [ __ ]
put incense in there I had to wipe down
the walls my wife goes you can't take
the smell of weed out of it
these kids are gonna come in here
they're gonna get stoned to the gills
we had a mop the floor time time
yeah there was more weed on that [ __ ]
floor and most weed stores
and that's and I clean that bathroom
twice three times a week yes we try can
you clean the corners out there's weed
everywhere my bathroom I get a [ __ ]
tank that night I go home now and I get
higher on the weed than I do on the
edibles sometimes it happens quicker yes
we smoked that thing that happened to
you that day that was no spike nobody
put nothing in your water yeah that was
basically one bong it's not little
it's a three-foot bong let's never
forget that okay it's a bond with
authority yeah that bong will [ __ ]
kill a human person that that's not a
regular bun let's not for regular people
Brett right like no yeah I came here by
the month maybe five weeks ago I trained
the Sundays my wife goes to church so I
got a three hour window mmm
so I try to write something train and
maybe go to cryotherapy by the time they
get back and I sit with my daughter
sometimes I do a podcast sometimes I
just watched movies of my daughter and
last night she opened up her salon and
she dyed my hair pink it was
tremendously washed it off and she saw
me on the way out she got pissed off I'm
just thinking about you dying your hair
pink you dyed it pink really do she's
the boss do what you gotta do okay she's
opening up businesses she sat me down
she had an appointment book she did she
ain't besides up like a wave the real
deal dawg yeah saw the way out she's
like you watched it out but I had to
take a shower you know I gotta go to
work I can't go paint can I go but
tomorrow night you could dye my hair
blue and she goes tomorrow night the
salons closed its Mondays on Monday
what's going on Jake Ellenberger you
look good too you retired thank you yeah
these are the questions we couldn't get
out of your life yeah I know I know you
officially retire them in your 33 you're
a young man yeah I mean I'm
what a [ __ ] mind to get into yeah
want to bind together into anything and
then you realize that there's a thing
called the family and you have to think
about that I know it I know life is very
simple but have life without a family it
gets hard along the way and one day you
do that like house yeah dad was taking
about okay so now us three would you're
30 you're 20 you're 33 let's pretend I'm
31
mmm and we start like a crime sitting
out here and we'll make money we'll make
a [ __ ] million a week between three
of us we chopping it up we're paying off
cops or something coke whatever the [ __ ]
now we hired two other guys and start
killing live with drug dealers and next
you know we'll make a 9 million a week
and we're chopping that up and actually
no we've created a criminal empire we're
not the Mafia with just a set of guys
that got together we trust each other
till the end they were making money
every week
this goes on for six [ __ ] years and
then one day something happens you meet
the woman of your [ __ ] dreams and you
have three [ __ ] kids you start
spitting out kids and one day you look
at your kids and you go holy [ __ ] I
gotta go out and kill Lee tonight and
put them in the [ __ ] hole what was
your look you know the answer that like
with comedy and then and fighting
fighting I'm not even thinking about
your kids and a money-wise I'm taking
about kids having you as a dad right
right fully being they're not [ __ ]
squeezing a ball and swatting flies on
imagine their hands yeah having Vietnam
flashbacks and 4:00 in the morning going
into their room yes all along the wall
so you know you gotta think about head
injuries yeah yeah no I know that's
that's kind of been my challenge to just
thinking about my future being there for
my kids you know giving them all the
time I want to give them and his life
changes fast you know I go you go it
like being a single guy it's easy you
know you can kind of float do what you
want to do train yeah when you got it
you got kids it's different you just
gotta think about their future more you
know so even for me like thinking about
fighting again like I think about it
every day you know I'm like I can I feel
well I feel great I for sure could fight
you know but I studying about my future
my kids future my hell
you know that's it that's like it's it's
definitely the most important so it's
it's tough though it's some one of the I
got a kid kind of continually analyzed
you know I'd be every week did you start
out at one of those gyms where sparring
sessions were street brawls you went all
out when I started no I'd say more like
like towards the middle of my career you
got a lot more sparring a lot more
intense that kind of thing but yeah not
not so much in the beginning did you
take a lot of shots to the head you
think I yeah yeah I mean I I have now
for sure I think it like I started about
maybe five five years ago five see you
know you start fighting guys that are
[ __ ] good everywhere it's fighting
guys like Stephen Thompson you know
there's just not there to their
traditional fighters you see or or even
guys you typically train with you know
so it's but yeah
I took something I fought Robbie Lawler
or fought Thompson oh you have a
tremendous resume I mean you're mean to
to [ __ ] you know [ __ ] joke yeah
I'm just saying that that's what you
really you know football players I mean
it's when I was growing up you didn't
hear about it I look at the kids I grew
up with a lot of them were you know
hands on running Hills with [ __ ]
barbells on their back type of football
team you know and they're all okay some
of them their hips are gone from all
those years of squatting heavyweights
yeah like that one of my friends that
was captain healthy had like a heart
issue but he's back lifting weights five
days a week and all that stuff but none
of them really have those traumatic head
injuries as much as like that Dan they
were banging heads those guys were doing
football you know we can I come from a
football high school man those guys took
promise [ __ ] them seriously I would hang
with them at night
yeah and idea about the beatings they
would inflict on each other and you know
the hatred between this guy and this guy
and they're fine you know fighting now
you don't know you know I know it's it's
hard to you know it's it's hard to see
because you know you don't see a lot of
the long-term effects still down the
road at least so yeah I mean even now
like I feel fine I feel great I feel
like I've always have but you know I
when I fought in Lincoln actually I met
with a like one of the top neurosurgeons
in the country and I was asking him I
talked to him for like three hours
asking him everything about CTE -
concussion he where he's like a
concussion specialist and he was talking
about you don't eat a bunch of tests
with me and there was nothing he could
see that was anything any sort of red
flag but he was like really the people
that are closest to you are gonna notice
there's any behavioral you know
differences or you know you go and
gamble all your money one day like some
some dramatic changes you know in your
behavior but he was even he went too far
says that there's no direct correlation
between concussions and CTE and I was
like I was kind of blown away there but
uh even like you're saying there's some
people like who were in boxing or
football I've done some hard contact
sports their whole life and are never
affected you know they're fine and
there's some guys like you know you're
like the junior Seau's and the guys like
that it's there's like a certain type of
protein I guess in a lot of these people
they found CTE like some type of protein
in their brain you know so he but he was
like there's no you don't have a better
chance of having CTE than most people so
I was like yes that was and that was
interesting I had kind of bloomin blew
my mind a little bit
so look wait how did you start I started
fighting 2005 like back then were you
planning for this already like you know
you had to like be careful or you just
went in there like I just want to fight
no I was yeah it was one of those you
know 2005 like you see you see Chuck
Liddell you see Tito Ortiz see all these
guys and I just I like training training
was a hobby it was fun and I never even
anticipated making fighting a career you
know and then just kept getting more
opportunity like the more the better you
do
the more just like how about this fight
how about this fight is like and then
you're getting paid and that's like [ __ ]
but yeah you don't really stop and think
about it until like I'll tell you when I
really started like when I had when I
had kids you know my son Jameson's three
and a half and that's when I was really
like start thinking about head trauma
injuries you know my future his future I
want to be there for him you know when
he's least graduating school that kind
of things it's uh you know I watched
that movie with Will Smith and then what
happened to these guys and I remember
the stories as they happen and it's
really sad you know I know for a fact I
had a concussion one time and it [ __ ]
me up for awhile I get did [ __ ] me up oh
there was a mild I got hit and I fell
off a motorcycle that was it I hit him
fight Jesus son well ya gonna [ __ ]
fight him by God I wore helmet yeah
thanks Adam early age I was smart enough
I knew riding yes I took my daughter to
the park and then we walked with the
schooler with the helmet there and then
she [ __ ] does 90 miles an hour
22 times around park without with the
helmet then she came brought me down but
she doesn't wanna go to monkey bars
there's some kids showed up and I see
them put two feet on the [ __ ] scooter
and I stopped it and she started crying
she doesn't but I want to ride his
scooter I know you gotta put the [ __ ]
helmet on you know and I thought about
why I was so strict about it was because
even when I was 12 I was a motorcycle
freak but something always made me wear
a helmet Mike there there pull it why
not
yeah you know I even wore elbow pads
well I broke because it was just dirt
right bike hmm I was a dirt bike guy so
we would ride where the giant stadium is
now that was a swamp back there and we
were able to take motorcycles from one
County to another and back and the
we had an area down there we did jumps
off day listen it was funny when you're
13 that's what it's all about sure it
was there was a mile of of cars that you
had to go through that you had to be
careful and I Drive the other way the
cops are gonna stop you anyway right
and those days a cop that would stop you
anyway I chase you so you just went and
you prayed that there was no cops and I
knew the dangers of a motorcycle hmm and
I was we weren't racing but it ii
fuss-free went on motorcycles and were
[ __ ] with each other [ __ ] you lady
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up on one of those
[ __ ] you Li's I turned and there was a
pipe sticking out of the ground and then
hit the helmet it took me right off and
next thing you know I remember calling
into a friend's car and next you know
I'm at the [ __ ] hospital there was
like I remembered events looking at it
today it was like taking pictures of
events like one minute I was on my back
the next minute you know they were
carrying me the next thing I remember
I'm in a car and I'm like where's my
motorcycle your motorcycles fine we'll
come back and get it
mmm the next minute I was at a hospital
the next without my mother was there
about to smack the [ __ ] out of me in
your hospital bed and then I was in like
when I got off I puked that night they
did all those things those tests mm-hmm
I got really really sick my vision
started to blur a little bit for a few
days
yeah I couldn't say this because they
would keep me in the hospital last thing
I want in those days so I lied myself
out of it Jesus so it was just like for
three weeks I felt that something wasn't
right sure the mind is weird
there was a batch of cocaine I can't hit
the mold at one time seriously this
batch of cocaine came into mold that was
so pure it was like 1994 and I didn't
have a car I had a bicycle that
something I'll never forget getting high
on it that night and like getting
electroshocks on that like it was so
[ __ ] good
then I got a lecture shocked alright
when I woke up the next day I had the
same feeling like if I had a concussion
and I remember thinking I gotta get some
more that keistered riding a bicycle to
the Delhi zone right around the corner
from the puddle car wash cars sitting
behind me and I remember going oh my god
I've lost my mind
mmm like I don't know what's going on I
just know I'm alive
but I really don't have that's the
thought yes into my concussion thought I
can't do I worry about it you got to
worry about every shot he took go ahead
as a kid I took a lunchbox to the head I
take a couple kicks to the head yeah
Ronnie class sure what is it like
getting punched in the face like the
first time like I hit let's try a Z
no thank you all right then what do you
want to know though you know like it's
not good I'll tell you that yeah wait
when you're like when you're no fight
your your Adrenaline's going you don't
feel it at all
I mean a little bit yeah you do you just
I guess it just kind of depends I mean
you're so in the moment you're so like
savage in mode you know what I mean yes
oh [ __ ] you at the moment yeah that is I
don't know how you guys do it you I get
exactly look at my face I get anxiety
just thinking about okay I go out to my
car right now I'm good daily love you
thank you buddy how correlated it tore
me let's go downstairs let's walk out me
and Jake are walking out when Jake gets
in his car something that pulls over and
goes how you [ __ ] honky punk your
mother in the ass Jake says what are you
talking about the guy gets out of his
car the guy throws a punch of JJ truth
punches at him they wrestle for five
minutes I come down the stairs the guy
from the funeral parlor comes out we
break them up and you get in your car
that happens every day in America okay
let your car and your Adrenaline's going
and your lip is cut and your knuckle is
bruised and you get in your car and the
fights over with I could live with that
that happens every day in America I was
raised for that to happen
yeah six weeks ago I went to New York
and some guys stepped in front of me and
my daughter with me I don't care but
this is a kid absolutely I drew an elbow
Adam
I threw a shoulder adding he looked him
and they go excuse me and then he looked
at me and he said excuse me okay I don't
know maybe I was raised the wrong way or
something but that's one thing living in
the moment me calling Jake and going hey
Jake I heard you talking [ __ ] about me
[ __ ] do you ever see 232 [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I don't like Cubans [ __ ]
you I don't like pieces of Orange County
and Omaha Nebraska and then talking [ __ ]
and having an argument at the press
conference I would have a nervous
breakdown
if I'd have an argument with somebody
had a press conference you don't want to
do that not in a million [ __ ] years I
know you like and then wait for six
weeks to fight somebody that's insomnia
for me and then wake up that Saturday
what if you wake up that setting you
know you know what I'm not the mood to
fight today I'm having a great day I'm
feeling my G yeah I'm feeling good I
don't feel like smacking somebody today
oh my god why would you feel good you
gotta be angry this Naxal oh you know
work yourself up to get the ring you
know some people fight better after they
get [ __ ] up for a minute for sure take
a couple shots for the head then your
blood starts rushing with you you know a
really [ __ ] way sharply so that I
that I do not understand so what are you
most worried about but I guarantee
there's people drivin listening don't
whoa whoa whoa what about you drive to
the Comi store that's true right okay
yeah but I know that day so I suffer
with it that day but the suffer with it
from you to call me and say we're
fighting fourth of July weekend it's
[ __ ] January 20 yeah I got six months
of torture sitting here I gotta put a
picture Jake up on my wall shadow box in
front of them and make believe and then
I find that he's got three kids and a
wife in it and he's a nice guy how am I
gonna find him I got no beef with this
because this is what concerns me you
asked me about the mind yeah how the
mind works
I would [ __ ] my pants if I had to fight
somebody
six weeks like fight camp that walk they
do in the beginning when you come out
and you [ __ ] throw punches and you
gotta stand that when my hands are up
and that guy is searching me before you
ask me about the mouthpiece I just start
running you like I would just start
rather before I let them know did you
bring them out be not a the pale when
Jody is going what to get them out
Phoenix you know I got a [ __ ] best
done a pair of [ __ ] sandals and I'm
in my car headed north
yes yeah they'll never see me again that
is when they put their hands up and the
guy searches you right there I'm done
once I go TSA to fight somebody I'm done
I'm done yet then you gotta walk into
the ring and make believe like
everything is beautiful and then the
music starts and the other idiot walks
in and you gotta watch this boar I'm
walking and then run around in circles
and now this guy's running around in
circles and I'm thinking I gotta fight
this [ __ ] guy mmm he's running around
in circles or something I did this all
this process scares the living [ __ ] out
of me six weeks I gotta fight you I
don't know how I'm gonna feel this six
weeks you know what I feel like fighting
it but I don't want to fight you you
know I want to fight the [ __ ] field
goal guy from the red you know yeah
that's how you feel some day yeah I want
to fight the mechanic didn't take my
[ __ ] car right I don't want to fight
Lee I don't no time to fight leave it's
it's so different with these [ __ ]
massive crowds you know - I thought it
Rogers Centre in Toronto there's 56,000
people the walk from the [ __ ] locker
room to the cage was like a literally
five minute walk yeah I'm tired my
stress I would just drop my knees a drop
my heart no have you ever had line to a
fight or gone like really late on the
car yeah because that's the part that
would kill me Oh like the waiting what
everyone else is fighting worst part
it's waiting ah I get it like for me
even when I I got to thinking that like
when I do first thing I do when I need
to walk from my [ __ ] home asleep
I gotta fall asleep I don't know every
fight yeah I do cuz then it just shuts
everything off you forget about it but
the more you think about it you're like
right because that's the hardest part is
the waiting game because all the anxiety
building yeah it's and it's different if
you you know you go out in the
schoolyard or behind a locker room and
you get in a fight with some dude no but
nobody sees it but now you got a guy
who's been training for ten weeks he
wants to [ __ ] rip your head off in
front of a hundred million people you
know what I mean it's it's a difference
the psychology is different it's a it's
a trip I don't know how I've learned
from it when I watch it I put myself in
their shoes like I put myself running
down the ramp like I go how would that
feel yeah to run down there I'm you know
I you know I always see homeless people
like when you make the left on [ __ ]
Riverside and 2-1 know that Cahuenga
they got that homeless Hut there I said
tons I'm sitting at the light my hand
I'd trade places I don't give you about
you I think I puts a laundry cart up and
he's got like a ladder and he puts a
[ __ ] cheater and he sleeps under
there yeah that's where he [ __ ] sleeps
that's his little apartment and
sometimes when I go to sleep at night I
put to sleep apnea mascot la now like I
wonder how the [ __ ] that guy's doing it
and I make-believe like I'm sleeping
cars are going past me and you imagine
sleep on the street now what cars are
doing [ __ ] 30 miles an hour past you
all my drunk driver fell on bottles and
[ __ ] oh my god mm-hmm there's so a lot
of people in LA who live in their cars
or RVs I know I they have more I don't
know what it is yeah I don't know if I
could do that I think if I get to that
point I'd probably move home really
that's it that's a different kind of
commitment I guess well ince then thank
God I just haven't been in that
situation but that's just like the first
night you're sleeping you're crate like
[ __ ] I can't no yeah you live in
Milwaukee Wisconsin you train a dog
Rufus you're 22 you're good-looking you
know I'm just saying you know and
Duke has three really good fighters in
this camp maybe for whatever I don't
know I don't know Duke Rufus is roster I
know he's got tyron woodley whatever I
don't even know anymore but you just
feel like you want to go to a different
camp you want to come to the camp in
Sacramento you feel that you're a 145
and you want to train with those guys or
you want to go to Colorado and train
with bang okay and then hang out with TJ
Dillashaw cuz you and TJ I built the
same way and you can learn a lot and TJ
so you usually have one 400 in the bank
when you're 22 or 23 you've been working
you got a half a girlfriend you losing
your bed basically yeah and you get your
[ __ ] car and you dream mr. B in the
UFC your dream is for a life for getting
punched in the head you think you're
thinking about getting punched in the
head when you're 23 it's the last thing
I think about when I was doing coke and
putting coke from my nose
did you think I was worried about being
a 56 with a child and then you know no
no I didn't think about the future you
don't when you fall in love with
something you don't think about the
future
mhm she's a [ __ ] meth [ __ ] and you
wanna fall in love with away in 10 years
the futures no teeth and [ __ ]
disability and a [ __ ] all whacked up
you know I mean I'm just saying guys you
know you have to look at something we
don't think of my position with 23 so
you fall in love with something now what
mm you know so now you want to train
that whatever TJ Dillashaw is can't what
do you think people wait for you and
open arms
you get in your car but you find out
that the train with TJ Dillashaw
you gotta train in there between 9:00 in
the morning and one that eliminates most
[ __ ] jobs that eliminate 60% of
[ __ ] workforce so you got to start
from the bottom you gotta live in your
car and work in a restaurant isn't
[ __ ] as a [ __ ] busboy at night
until you become away then you know what
lis guess what you figure it the [ __ ]
out you figure out the hotel's you could
park in front of
going to their bathroom without security
and then you fall in love with the front
desk girl when she tells you when to
come I should let you sleep in the back
of the morning you could figure out how
to go in there and sneak a pack of
[ __ ] oatmeal and by tipping the girl
you just life [ __ ] that's the
sacrifice you make and then you go to
the gym one day you become friends with
the guys and you become a me or a hard
worker and one day the guy goes hey I
need a roommate to share a house and you
can have the basement for 300 a month
but for six weeks you gotta live in your
[ __ ] car that's part of the love that
you have for what you're about to do you
don't think about repercussions there's
and there's no repercussions we live in
the moment
mmm that's it mm-hmm no I get it and and
I think maybe he's different if you're
starting out it's whenever I see it I
think about myself I met a girl
that was dressed to the nines at the
comedy store with a guy and we were
talking having a great conversation hmm
and she told me she was homeless
remember the hooker ain't told me about
yeah she was home even if she was
homeless
she lived in a [ __ ] car by the saddle
ranch in the park mm-hmm in the parking
lot at the saddle ranch I mean guys you
know she wants to be an actress but she
thinks that you could just sign with an
agency Wow she doesn't know that you
have to go to acting class and you know
they think that they confused is the
prettiest girl in they bud hmm and they
come to Holloway and they don't know
that every day a bus empties out of a
hundred of the hottest women in the
world
the [ __ ] LA or Miami during Marsh
model season they go down to Miami you
know it's just the way life is but they
think because they they won't they one
more friendly to succeed they're gonna
go to the standard and then get a
[ __ ] job and a movie well then two
years later you crime that you suck
Harvey Weinstein's dick because the
process is [ __ ] you gotta go to acting
class and learn how to hack them but
buckle and then agents will be
interested in you it's a tight [ __ ]
economy here well just getting back to
your question it's just
it's not that you let yourself get to
that level it's what you're doing for
you drain mmm if you think you're a good
artist whatever you want Venice Beach
and you don't have enough money enough
let's go
I hate these don't you hate people are
looking at me though you know what it
doesn't really matter because I'm moving
to Oklahoma Nebraska February 2021
good luck yeah yeah good luck
those people drive me crazy yeah and
somebody says to me one a year and a
half
we're moving to calibrate it people who
gotta go big go yeah exactly when
somebody go they go there's no looking
back there's no year to save money well
I need a year to put away money you just
make an excuse to straight exactly
you're just making their shoes
bullshitting yourself take what you got
go to Grandma say grandma you're gonna
die no you gonna leave me five hundred
forget the five why'd you give me 300 N
with square I agree
get this 300 from Grandma borrow another
two from a friend of yours
maybe 500 you come out here with your
car and that's what most people do yeah
do I think it's the thing to do if you
really love it you have a [ __ ] plan
yeah if you believe in what you're about
to do find a way you find the [ __ ]
way yeah but if you're gonna come out
here because your cousins friends would
[ __ ] lease I act and he's gonna hook
you up
yeah they're gonna hook me up though I
hate people say I'll make a call to the
UFC Jake knows I'm going to frontage it
the best people will come and try to
impress you mmm free I can't do nothing
for you yeah I'm not gonna lie to you
and tell you I could do something for
you yeah I know I can't there's nothing
I can do fee I can open up certain doors
for you and you have to go through them
like the [ __ ] rhinoceros yeah but I
can't do nothing for you you still gotta
put in the work yeah and you still got
it is this podcast better yeah just say
no that's good it's a lovely [ __ ] day
I know say no to drugs I can interact
yeah yeah yeah but we usually do your
pocket yeah
half a little cake Banga but I bet you
get hit up all the time at the same [ __ ]
like I know for me like I get people
like I can't even tell you how many
messes I get people want me to introduce
them to Sean Shelby or Dana or like hey
I've been fighting I got three fights or
I want to be I feel like I have [ __ ]
every day every and I'm like again it's
like you got you you got to do the work
you got a can you fight okay like you're
me I may be able to introduce you to
somebody but it's not just gonna [ __ ]
in the snap of the fingers you're
fighting in the UFC it's not gonna
happen you know like I get people
hitting me about fighting in the
contender series and you know get me on
you know what I mean I'm sure you
probably do the same [ __ ] but it's years
ago the best one I ever got for Rogan
was a guy that told me mr. Diaz I don't
mean to bother you but I keep sending
Rogan message is only well he won't get
back to me I mean I used to get those
all the time yet really won't get back
to me I'm sure you have a way to get in
touch of Dana White let me tell you my
situation I'm 14 and all with 16
knockouts
you know I knocked out the judge about
everybody yeah oh my god
this guy had a link on YouTube and I
went to him and he had no fights on it
it was just him hit the bag knows
tateleh I'm head to toe yeah he had the
knee brace on he had the expensive
shorts the gloves and he's beating the
bag and he goes this is pure power and
he's calling people out on the bag yeah
and I'm like if you're 14 a no you must
have fight footage why would you send
your rogue on a tape of you in the bag I
thought he was just like oh maybe the
guy's creative maybe the guy's artistic
maybe it's him talking to his first
before his fight footage it was four
minutes of five minutes long I wanted to
shoot myself I'm gonna watch it cuz he
saved me and I was waiting to see him
narrate his own fights yeah this is me
in Japan it's him you know had kicking
somebody
this is rain Russian him taken somebody
in a [ __ ] single yes amid them with a
[ __ ] Chamorro ism it was just him on
a bag going nobody wants this right hand
not TJ Dillashaw not yeah Mighty Mouse
he called that John Jones robbed last
night
yeah and he was doing nothing hood bag I
can see like if the bag blew up in
friendly everywhere yeah I mean that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh well I saw the video
he was tatted from an ankle to his neck
I go he had just done a shot of steroids
mmm I mean he was jacked yeah - the [ __ ]
yo guys he really know how to punch and
I'm no [ __ ] Gerry Cooney I don't know
about boxing yes but I know a punch when
I see red red did he leave a comment did
I leave a comment you know I would never
[ __ ] leave a comment no no no no no
yeah those type of people you leave a
comment like that next thing you know
you don't know but they jump out a
window
yeah they're that crazy the send Joey
did a video to send the vein of white to
show them how tough you are and that you
afford Tina no and there's no fights
that guy jumps out a window gets hit by
a car that night on purpose yeah or
takes his own life that that's but you
can't I know I love people there was a
guy I thought he would say but he kept
sending me email saying someone was
torturing him
so you gotta make it stop man they're
doing terrible things to me I can't was
part of that though there's a guy who
told me he wanted to kill me once but
like that guy what I don't know he just
said I mean he was saying I hope it
doesn't matter but like yeah they
sometimes get a crazy start a where I
get the craziest stuff messenger I don't
know I don't know Facebook does that on
purpose yeah but could creepiest thing I
get is every time I click the messenger
mmm and
forty unread messages and your stall to
the gills and your reading and some of
them a nice nice American what just nice
people
yeah I should say American that
worldwide but there's ten of them
there's one guy now that I have no idea
what he's talking no idea I'd [ __ ] with
the vegan one yeah I don't take the
medication you know yeah well I don't I
don't put him down
I just tell them I take the medication I
could see when somebody online is
starting to lose it like at this point
you could see this is not gonna end well
there's a guy that hits me up every time
I go to New York City I never hear from
him year-round
I hear from him the weekend ball in New
York City and it's always the same story
he wants help he has a heroin problem
and he wants me to help him and bring
him out here and he wants to replace Lee
he would be better than Lee and they and
you gotta hear this [ __ ] damn and it's
always a star like I'm gonna I'm gonna
be Ari's producer so I called army you
know this guy is he does know he hit me
too
I've got only watching the other show
there's some crazy people I'm them and
if we get that could you imagine poor
Rogan and I've never seen one Rogan post
on Instagram if you learn about myself
it is something there's times I just
check his Instagram just to see what
people say yeah he could put on a
[ __ ] picture of a dinosaur up and he
could be one of his intelligence modes
ago and put a picture of a scientist
found 30 thousand year old elephant
bones you know hope or something like
that I'm and there's people like who's
gonna win could be bacana
that would GMT 100% you know they don't
leave along with the DMT that was ten
years ago and leaving oil it secondly
somebody calls me big [ __ ] from the
Sopranos or somebody comes up to me now
and says I listen to the podcasts all
the time
you have any stars at that Tanya he just
look at him ignore them cause you're not
listening to the podcast because we have
another star death and [ __ ] a year
now
yeah only Lee's got a bag nobody snowy
those things yeah they work I don't ever
want to see those [ __ ] things again
that nasty taste appreciated yeah yeah
now they got they're a year old they're
[ __ ] over expired I came in the
fridge you kept them in the fridge
[ __ ] crazy you have the company that
has like the roll the foam roll yeah the
high price comes against you yeah yeah
no they're doing well yeah they're doing
well yeah guy got a couple investments
I've made so they're doing pretty well
we got a restaurant actually about to
open in West Hollywood they're about to
open up but taken Louie
so what kind of Russia uh well there's
one downtown called Bottega Louie oh
yeah yeah I went there they got a lot of
pastries and macarons that kind of stuff
but good food
one of my buddies I went to I grew up
with he's like there he went to USC he's
an architect like super [ __ ] brilliant
guy he's their architect but uh yeah we
he I invested in their their new one
they're about to open so like this
sometime this year but that's it's
keeping me busy so next time he comes
he's gonna be coming in a Bentley that's
like one of the places in downtown that
like girls really like to go like yeah
Leo place pictures and that's a good leg
it's always be open always it's like one
of the highest rated bakeries ever
really yeah yes I gotta take your vests
in these things yeah what did the new
one they're about to open I did yeah so
they're the other they're killing it
are you gonna be like a working partner
or just like behind the scenes I owe you
money
I want a little money back every year
right yeah I'm just kinda behind the
scenes you know so but yeah I might I'm
open to you don't want a Goodfellas yeah
yeah I'm gonna get cooking yeah I got
start going in there start
patan for donuts and [ __ ] me yeah
then when they come to me a zero is
3,000 what are you gonna pay us I smack
the manager yeah yeah I'm gonna call
this number
yeah or your partner's no no we like it
and we go through it like The Sopranos
you just start ordering bags of flour
yeah sorrel and then one day we just
like to join them that's it [ __ ] Jewish
stop and if he walks away debt free yeah
I will check it booth handy clean and no
more cupcakes no more [ __ ] cupcakes
is shitty when you watch a fight now how
do you feel
did you watch this weekend's fights yeah
yeah and how do you feel as you're
sitting there watching these fights now
it's you know Mirai I analyze a lot of
fights and stuff and I I mean for me
I'll expect a lot a lot of my fights and
I just think about like you know it's
hard to like not overanalyze yourself as
far as I could have done this better I
can I got a buddy
Ethan suppli he's an actor and he's on
the podcast oh yeah a great guy Greg
you've never watched anything he's ever
done blew my mind never watched a film a
show I thought he was that he was joking
he's like no I like you're serious and
he he's never watched some he's done and
he because he's very critical himself
you know I could I didn't like this I
couldn't like I understand it I get it
but for me even like I look at my fights
it's hard to watch on my fights like
even that have been like real close
where I could have done this or I
[ __ ] knocked him down got back up and
he can't kick me she knows so I I I like
watching fights but my fights are a
little harder because it's like you
tried to overthink [ __ ] and I could have
done this or strategy you know but I
mean it helps guy like I still help
other guys train too so I can kind of
give give back a little bit to them as
far as reflect on the [ __ ] I more I made
mistakes you know things that I could
have done better but it's funny when I
watch a fight as a fan but I also watch
to learn I'm watching I think about what
they're thinking about
I'm watching a baseball game like before
the pike tennis we're talking to my Tom
Brady hmm like what are you thinking
about the sidelines yeah well you got
that ball back with 54 second I know 39
39 seconds and what were you thinking
about when you won the toss and how you
walk out there you well this is all
going on there's nobody I'm watching a
football game but I'm trying to put my
head where he's at right now you know
this I don't know 11 people on the other
side that wanna kill me
they wanna [ __ ] take my [ __ ] head
off blow your knee out balm on the other
side and they're monsters they're not
just any people I mean it's looking
[ __ ] you know they all run a 4 to 40
yeah yeah I mean this is [ __ ] savage
you you you're 41 years old which
naturally you've lost a step which he
had right right so what are you thinking
what is on your mind how do you prepare
for that
come here is that has always been my
quest like and what I like about
fighting is ok so the other night I told
you I watched it two times khabib
against Conor after two beep taps out
you sitting there you breathe in what's
going through yet the things you didn't
work on hmm the day that he went to the
museum with your wife instead of going
through Jitsu yeah you think about the
night you didn't know and do strength
and conditioning right ankle hurt but it
really didn't right you think about you
know when I get on stage and I hate a
bag of dicks and people are yeah so
thanks for coming and all that I'm
talking to them but I'm really in the
moment but I'm breaking down just what
what just happened hmm I get in the car
called Li I bust his balls once he hangs
up the rest of the ride home is breaking
down my set what happened how I felt you
know I might have up stage 11:30 but I
can't go to bed till 1:00 or 1:30
because that's what's racing through
your mind that Joe worked that [ __ ]
joke toward like last night I just
wanted to get something out I wanted to
make sure I covered this and I did two
of the
resets yeah which for a gal like me is a
win all I wanted to do is sparring last
night was work a two punch combo with a
faith
Superman kick and when you angle I get
you with the kick to the head on the
left side that's all I wanted to work on
last night I'm like I'm going down to
try this thing whether it [ __ ] kills
me cuz the worst thing is putting
something in a paper and going that's
gonna kill him
and then going down there and not doing
it yeah you know I talk about game plans
and fighting I've learned a lot about
game plans because I could tell what a
fighter is sticking to his game plan
mm-hmm when Conner fought Nick Diaz the
second time he wanted there with a game
plan I mean watch the fight when the guy
kicked his legs a thousand times yeah so
he implemented the leg kick he stayed
away from him he didn't let Nate get too
close to him and he lost him the second
time not if you watch it but he ended up
winning he made little adjustments in
his fighting I love that [ __ ] yeah
well I watch a fight and I could tell
that you made adjustments I love that
[ __ ] Diaz loves your on the hi-hat kick
and he goes low low low and he comes up
high if you time that head kick the
right way I'm a dead man
I kept some guy like you Jake hmm you're
gonna take me down with a single while
that leg is coming up on you and it's
easy night night after that cuz you're
taking me down hard I got one leg up in
the air if you time it you're done you
sweet right hand on my shoulder it's all
over the oxygen flows on you you start
throwing punches from underneath and all
sudden McCarthy comes in and weighs you
off you know and that's how I feel right
when I do stand-up when I get off the
stage those first two minutes I like to
just you're analyzing you set way you
went wrong way you should have been
better
yeah and what are you gonna work on the
next time mmm you know so that's I
compared a lot of [ __ ] in common yeah
MMA because it's an art no matter what
the only thing you don't have is weight
cutting
yeah thank God yeah imagine if you gotta
make wait for Friday's show every week
we you would never get never make wait
I never made that's the only difference
in the art is man wait it's still the
same [ __ ] thing
listen Joey's a jujitsu guy Jake when
you find them you got it throw the four
punch combo you know so I just want you
to work on four combo right cross low
kick and a high kick you know just mix
it up into four he can't take off for
delivery
that's what I would you know that's how
I cut that's how I practice my Tommy
that's how it works for me yeah to go
out there throw jabs and to expect an
ass-kicking make the adjustments just to
make the adjust that something awesome
just to make the adjustments because
guess what my combos gonna start with a
jab I'm gonna come over I'm gonna leg
kick him with a left and then I'm gonna
take two steps go to the head
maybe there's a step I'm taking mmm but
I'm not doing it right these are the
catch me went over with a overhand left
the first time mmm no I gotta get back
to position and trying to get moving
around a little bit maybe throw a head
kick at him take a Superman punch but
then after that I'm gonna run the same
combo again jab cross leg kick high kick
you know and hopefully and if I if I do
it and even if he blocks all four of
them if he knocks me I thought that I'm
good
there's like no I'm on to something this
is inspiring right this is inspiring mmm
if I see that he's it's I'm easily taken
down after I throw the second kick that
means he could read the second kick I
gotta make adjustments with that second
cake I gotta make adjustments if that
leg kick he's popular he's pleased of
blocking it you know he's what do you
fall out when you particular like he's
checking in here you know I can't have
him check it maybe I'm kicking too low
maybe I'm kicking too high but if I kick
him low I got his balance and I can
knock him off balance that I come out
I'm gonna with the left
these are the same things that Holliday
you have to expect that that's what I'm
not good at jiu-jitsu like to be the
legit so you have to know what that
guy's second move is gonna be before he
does it right you want him to put his
hand down mm-hmm like I just found that
but if you get me in a [ __ ] spider
guard
I can't pad even if it's the easiest
path it's a terrible mistake I just
found that I've survived years and I
would do it all the time and get swept
try to pull that [ __ ] spider guard on
me man all right because now I know it
the city still until you pull the guard
out oh I'll try just step aside and pull
your leg and hopefully I can cross pull
your leg and get on copy mmm I didn't
know that for years I would actually
pass your guard with one arm hang in
there like the [ __ ] 10 man is always
the funny yeah you know but to do it and
fail right it's the same thing with
comedy it's the same thing with anything
unless you try you can't [ __ ] fail
and you can't learn from mmm so but
that's the best thing that you have that
you have experience to share with yeah
the fighters to calm them down you know
I think sometimes young fighters like I
love to see young fighters that grow in
the UFC mmm like yourself he came at a
young age yeah and you grew up in the
EOC you took some wins you took some
losses then you figured it out for a
while
mm-hm then you figure that for a while
then you start having doubts and there
you go you know what happened that night
the worst thing you could happen is when
you start having doubts and we all have
I had him two weeks before I shot the
degenerate special yeah and it destroyed
my my performance you know I thought
that was great
well two weeks before I got doubts hmm I
started switching material I started
having doubts and you live and you learn
you at the right and I'm a veteran even
at the 26 year mark you still have
doubts mm which creates a whole
difference
scenario indefinitely I know I wish I
wish I would have looking back now I
wish I what it is we're sure to slow
down a little bit you know cuz when
you're finding that [ __ ] top level
competition you know you get you know
you make ups and downs you take some
lumps but I was like full speed ahead
you know sure I just wish I would have
slowed down a little bit kind of to
fight see we said you know kind of kind
of analyzed myself a little more you
know becoming a little more aware of
setup since like strategy like you're
talking about making adjustments like
those are those are the most important I
mean I was even watching Cowboys fight
this last weekend like that young kid it
was interesting cuz I you know everybody
who's a veteran like cowboy yeah they
know how that that young that young kid
is you just his reckless doesn't care
and that's a that's a hard guy to beat
but as soon as cowboy started getting
his distances range seeing how this guy
would for example that kid Hernandez he
would throw some good combinations but
he would back straight up and I could
see it I was like cowboy picks up on him
back and showed up he's gonna start
following him after he resets gonna
follow him back in and start laying it
straight upon any day he started tagging
him up and which ended up setting up
that head kick but that's one of those
things like as a veterinary you can see
you can pick up on those things and make
adjustments but that was a that was a
car you know a great fight by Cowboys I
have you seen the scam coming or have
you not seen the scam coming what SAS
six months after Conor McGregor lost the
movie convincingly they all sat down and
we had a pic they're not gonna give him
I knew you know I knew they're not gonna
give him the Spanish kid what's his name
Eddie's guy who was number one
so I 155 it's Tony
Enterprise Fergus yeah they're not gonna
give them Tony Ferguson there's no way
right now I can't take a little knock
out they can't take another
with him that's a hard fight Poirier got
dangerous yeah after you fight somebody
once pori improved 100% of 34 McGregor
mmm
you know holloway improved a hundred and
fifty percent yeah he fought McGregor
because once you see where your mistakes
were you just now you thought it was
supposed to be the best
you lost I'm going for it so all these
guys they don't want poori against
MacGregor but they had they told cowboy
six months ago you know have to be lost
to start dropping weight to go to 165
what is what is he ranked that ones 55
like cowboy cowboy yeah top ten I'm sure
7-6 maybe I don't even know see since
you're on the show we could talk about
this I feel that I think McGregor's next
fight should be that Spanish for
Ferguson that's my feeling about it yeah
but let me see who officers on that
you're not barboza
also has to be up there 153 yeah you've
got I don't think he's right right now
whoo hi cowboy he's got to be ranked
either 170 or 155 I check 170 yeah he's
still rising right now on the way this
is UFC UK let me take the zubur you use
not capital e yeah Tony way and then you
think about Tony may be fighting khabib
I don't know it's that's a good fight
they were supposed to fight that's just
a Mendes fight that's another fight that
people really really would like to say
yeah but I think he's been you know he
sees an easy opponent even cowboy and I
hope he doesn't really think Cowboys and
the be an easy opponent right okay you
know once cowboy gets into a rhythm mmm
he does okay yeah and again he's been
back in the rhythm I think he won his
last two yeah two or three so I
yes his last two or three so he might be
you know you get a cowboy when Cowboys
cowboy and you forget cowboy to jujitsu
yeah cowboy is not bad at Jitsu no he's
great
what does he how many submissions does
he have look at his record table boy has
good jujitsu yeah so don't underestimate
a lot of people loving that fight
already and I think Dana thinks that
yeah
McGregor can be cowboy and try to get
his status back
I think cowboy might be a little tougher
them what do you [ __ ] think so yeah
you fought cowboy Wow no no not under
[ __ ] cowboy no yeah okay I'm assuming
this is updated I'm not sure but I'm
Lucy's website says nine wins by
knockout seventeen by submission eight
by decision yeah
jujitsu game is your [ __ ] job it's
good so I hope that they don't think
that they get like an old cowboy yeah
that because if cowboy decides to fight
Conor McGregor trust me he's going to
[ __ ] train hard for that [ __ ] oh yeah
and he's Muay Thai is sensational yeah
you know he's not this Muay Thai has
always impressed me but his submission
game ain't bad
so this might not be an easy fight uh
this is an easy fight hell no this isn't
gonna be an easy fight they'll mean the
UFC is kinda like what you were saying
earlier it was like the pretty girls who
come like from all over like and it's
kind of crazy like every fight in the
UFC or at really any organization that
was like the best like that even though
even if they lose like they're like the
best of the best that's pretty crazy to
have to like fight that guy fight what
guy like it's like that's the part that
gets me is like there's so much like the
other guy's great it's not like it's not
like you're fighting like you know
you're gonna win well you never know
no no they make up some cards that you
sit down scratch ahead
I mean who saw cyborg get knocked out
against noon at all I know who saw Henry
Saru imagined cyborg death like that's
scary
I had a feeling I had a feeling about
yeah but she's just [ __ ] slick yeah
and she my she can [ __ ] hit didn't
surprise me
inhundred surprise me Henry Sehun uh
over tilicho this weekend mm-hmm
surprised I didn't watch it I was just
real right I'm not getting yes but I
didn't know they threw a [ __ ] by the
way I yeah why can't the UFC just be
square with you why can't I was telling
my wife that in society today you avoid
thinking about it but no matter what you
do at every level you get [ __ ] Lee
whatever I totally the first thing he'll
tell me is I like that city I my pet
hotel but they try 38 the park she tells
me about parking constantly Lee knows
every parking rate across the [ __ ]
country and that's good and it's bad it
scares me
mmm no we was gonna get a piece of ass
and the hotel he called me one night and
Sunday night but it's 38 to park and you
know what am i out there you know last
thing you went to court he wouldn't pay
the ten the park next to the courtroom
it's all tens 20 20 oh I was there for
two days and here's the killer we free
parking here's the killer about that
that I don't even know what the [ __ ]
point is I don't I'm saying this for the
part when you go out anymore you really
try to have a good time and then you
walk home
you get home and you realize what you
spent for the day mm-hmm and you realize
like you get [ __ ] I see these point
Achatz are paid for yeah I see the
amount I pay for cars and all this [ __ ]
I see the amount that they want for
Super Bowl tickets we were just
discussing its remote sensing the amount
they want for tickets and mmm you know I
just heard through the grapevine that
ticketron sells tickets but they don't
boat they bought a company who buys
those tickets and doubles the price on
themselves and the scalpers you know so
as a consumer in today's world we turn a
blind eye to it but you feel like he
getting [ __ ] with every level mmm I
love to go to a Laker game but I'm not
paying 189 to sit all the way up in the
top under the air conditioner
and then I gotta pay another 50 the
[ __ ] par now yeah and then you know
something I spoke with somebody then why
are you going to the Rams playoff game
two weeks ago not the one this week
against the wall needs to week earlier
and they said I thought about it because
I went online and they go Joey it was
gonna cost like 500 to go to that game
and the [ __ ] rain because you know
what I saved the 500 and I watched that
homeland enjoyed myself yeah I want you
to think about something mmm five
hundred dollars
who has five hundred dollars to go to a
[ __ ] football game they have 800,000
people are not getting a [ __ ] check
right now 800 people well I flew the
other day I think every ball of Tears
agents I thanked them to their [ __ ]
faces I was like hey man thank you for
being it I can't even imagine going
somewhere and not getting paid right now
mm you know Lee and I have discussed it
8:00 on the house for floor seats at the
Rolling Stones and 15 apart and it's 12
for water so if you're not coming to
home as an American consumer wearing
gone
I just got [ __ ] hmm you know they
don't let you [ __ ] the smuggled water
during TSA they make you throw the water
away why because you got to pay four
dollars in the [ __ ] Airport mmm it
won't you at the airport two hours
earlier wise you sit there no so you
spend money on their overpriced [ __ ]
food then you know they shouldn't shut
out blood no matter what level of this I
think that yeah place the air man my
stomach was [ __ ] sick at the airport
no matter where the [ __ ] eat so isn't it
even I feel sometimes I go somewhere
that go man that was pretty good and
then my wife would go it was fifty four
hours for four hot dogs anyway I just
got [ __ ] in the ass you're right yeah
you know I don't take it for a UFC event
you know and it's not the ticket to the
event
it's everything that goes on yeah
they've eliminated the class of this
country they were eliminating the class
especially like for me it's
it's hard but like this is dealing
tougher when you're in a relationship
probably what if you're married with
kids and you have to buy four times oh
yeah
like guys yeah you've gotta fly
somewhere 1,300 I see people flying a
lot I do it with two kids and they don't
give a [ __ ] that I have a special price
for kids
yeah or not that your kid flies for free
if he's under three that's it that's it
on the two and then it's to everybody
else [ __ ] pays that's a seat check we
want the wheel what if you said Tom my
lap that will listen it's our [ __ ]
lap yeah could you listen on our [ __ ]
jet can't what every level I have as a
consumer in America right now you like
you know what man
Jesus Christ you know when does the when
there's the [ __ ] stop like I said I
feel bad for this generation that they
can't go to a baseball game so [ __ ]
twenty bucks
I'm gonna get Dodger tickets for 20
[ __ ] bucks see what you get you get
an earphone and a cup let you listen to
a war yeah okay they tell you go around
the back take that cup and put it
against the thing you'll hear the game
perfectly that's what you get for 10
bucks I need to pay like 12 bucks for a
Knick ticket 15 bucks for a Knick think
I ran that means a fork three of my kids
go or me and my wife and two kids
it's 60 bucks it's New York City I'm
gonna get banged out anyway but you know
Tom Horne maybe some [ __ ] cotton
candy maybe a box of raisinettes you go
to a movie today in America how much is
the [ __ ] movie 15 bucks 20 bucks
you walk out a little over your dirty
life you don't like it that's what
validating parking you gotta [ __ ] get
validation hey Johnny yeah it's the most
embarrassing thing in the [ __ ] world
even that Laemmle I gota you have to
take your stick if they validate it and
you still got to pay to get out of the
[ __ ] place there's a line by the
[ __ ] machine you got to stand there
for another [ __ ] out yeah so you [ __ ]
with every level I'm gonna take a [ __ ] I
just sat there for two hours to stuff
myself with popcorn
I got a blasted farts at the end of the
movie like I can't my wife's looking at
me like hold on it's gonna end in 20 men
I know they're popping popcorn oh yeah
[ __ ] crazy so a little bit it's yeah
and then you go to a place and walk them
out where you're from did you compare
the prices of what you're paying on
while for gas or you man large County
even New York City has cheaper gas no it
really yeah it's like two miles a gallon
chase I was telling I know I've told
some friends about my brother Jo's house
he bought his house see like five
bedrooms 130,000 they paid for it 100
think about the hundred and thirty
thousand he's got a family's got three
kids wife three kids a fighter all right
yeah yeah he doesn't he doesn't fight
anymore but I was like a hundred and
thirty that you couldn't buy walk you
can't even look at houses out here you
can't buy a tree for [ __ ] less than
[ __ ] help the housing this
neighborhood do you like a pace on the
bush you want to stay here now I I mean
I like it I do I like it out here I'd
like to I'd like the ideally have a
place a place out here and a place back
there so but as far as we're you know
we're raising kids I don't know I'm not
sure yeah I gotta I gotta figure that
out but I do I enjoy it I hear though
it's a lot of there's you know you get
20 minutes to the beach and plenty of
stuff to do but yet it's expensive so
you go to the beach a lot with your kids
in this one small yeah you check how far
are you from the beach yeah 20 minutes
yeah
so you used to be yeah yeah we use a
beach we go for a walk you know let the
kids play in the sand and [ __ ] and yeah
they love that but you know this is a
browser yeah I'll buy anyways family
there Arizona yeah not that some old
places if you decide to move there at
least you got support there yeah they
behave you still be cheaper they're not
here yet no no no makes [ __ ] sense
yeah
what are you so you're picking a fight
again
cause you and they all had it would have
to be fun I mean you have to be
financially worth it you know do you
still have the same management and
everything yeah sure you have somebody
cutting deals for you and stuff yeah
Bellator you don't want something that
serious I considered it but I don't know
it's hard it's hard it's just it's hard
to close that door you know what I mean
like training so much and just training
as long as I have and I don't know it's
I think I think about it a lot but yeah
I don't know then I have that realistic
talk with myself about my kids in the
future and let's let's not fight again
you know I I don't know like part yeah
my ego I want to fight for sure but when
I started thinking a more rational
logical dad Jake that I'm like God and
I'm done what a call to make like I
think me and I were having this
conversation about England New England
last night if Tom Brady wins at 41 years
old
that gives them how many rings we have
six or seven I think it's seven are you
[ __ ] sky seriously yeah so right now
if you're Tom Brady and you beat the
rents right at the end of the game do
you raise the [ __ ] trophy and say I'm
done he better not I've got enough money
yeah I've got 76 rings I mean when do
you say it's enough I know he's talked
about until 45 I don't think he does
he he doesn't even let them take himself
out what he's like leading by 30 at the
end of the fourth quarter know what
happened he likes being in there what
happens between you another two steps
and kids around you were getting
stronger they're coming into college a
lot stronger than they last you 19 of 20
and they're fast and they're stronger
and yeah they're limiting hits on
quarterbacks but remember there's a way
I could hurt you just you getting up 11
times just
knocking you down there was something I
spoke to a couple weeks ago you go to
Judah this kids mowing the toughest kids
I know did you tell you're gonna do know
you just know I don't why not he does I
just don't like getting up you know and
this kids 23 I just don't like getting
up okay throw me on my back because I
don't like it
I'd rather just stay down you know I
don't leave that [ __ ] so you know I mean
so think about these gonna so what do
you want to see do you want me to see
you getting sacked and thrown away that
seven year it's a seven or six years
beforehand what you've done Twitter
please you're not knowing when people
are yeah why do you [ __ ] with me give me
the exact information yeah why don't you
retire Jake when do you say I look at
myself in the mirror Jake that's when
the guy was like I'm 90 years old I feel
bad for people if they come to see me
now cuz I'm so [ __ ] old so I ask
myself every day when do you retire now
everybody in this room and every
whistles podcast knows if a guy like me
retires I die that's when I die like
that's yeah you always have to UM one of
those guys that I want to die working
you know I never wanna be living on a
yacht when I'm 65 and making boy hey
[ __ ] you gotta keep working I respect
these older guys that's really that keep
[ __ ] working
but that's something completely
different that's looks an image image I
read and what your mind can handle I'm
talking about when you're getting
[ __ ] hit for a living yeah that's a
complete different [ __ ] living yeah
how old when does a human being go
I've had enough Lee I want this take I'm
sorry I went to the wrong place
yeah no [ __ ] you've been going the wrong
page all afternoon and you're supposed
to be the computer phone you know what
you did I didn't do that one yeah Brady
I imagine he plays at least a couple
more
Lucy's an old wolf he's down with his
fingers if you want to talk over him say
what what is it NJ call him very look of
monkeys dad hi
he's captain with his [ __ ] fingers
look at this creepy little fingers look
you could tell his grandfather was a
diamond smuggler he's got natural that's
really you can't even yeah it doesn't
really matter guys I'm 41 years old yeah
your your wife is worth millions sure
you're worth million it'll be a 6-1 I'll
be his sixth ring
I think he's his 9th Superbowl he's five
and four I think 10th Super Bowl that's
just crazy guys he wins you turn around
you say sell every part of your contract
is they make you VP of entertainment
activities hmm and they give you a
salary of bass 350 years so you could
retain you insurance or them to [ __ ]
deal yeah you know when I was watching
Kansas City yesterday against them I
remember for a second that Joe Montana
went out yeah playing for the Kansas
City that's what I was a big Chiefs fan
yeah Marcus Allen oh yeah they all went
to Kansas City at the end and Joe did
okay Kansas City and I out of Kansas
City
yeah or somewhere else no he retired at
the end City well you still he had that
for ring like you see it yeah 49 49ers
you know and they took those two extra
3x3 years and he looked bad I don't ever
want to see Tom Brady look bad mm-hmm I
the other year when he got suspended I
was actually happy because all I really
need him before is the playoffs so I I
think if they draft the hope little
drafts like his next guy cuz he can't
play for that that much longer but I
think he still has like two to three
years left oh I think so and they're
gonna start put they're gonna start
paying him more to any but Ike we don't
give you [ __ ] three more million to
play this yeah I don't know I think he
takes it's aa [ __ ] decision now I
hope I don't know what how it's gonna
end if he loses I get and coming back
another year
okay if he wins in my heart I wish he
raised his hand says listen it's over
it's gonna be 20 years to guy shows up
lazier with six rings good luck and it's
against the team that he won his first
one again so I could see it being like a
surprise one I just the way I'm thinking
now I would be surprised but it does it
would be a good end to the story well
with Belichick too you know the coach oh
he better never leave they're like yeah
I feel he's BGM for life cuz yeah I
would say like that you were talking
about Sony Michelle and I was thinking
oh we had LeGarrette Blount going crazy
for a couple years he left and I was
like oh no knows maybe we'll have
touchdowns and that guy has like well
like six touchdowns in two games I
wasn't a contributor to it oh my god I
didn't contribute a dime to it I didn't
pay any attention to it at all
I checked the result and I knew they
were fighting when Tito and Chuck were
fighting it broke my heart
mmm it's hard to watch it broke my heart
I didn't wanna watch it that I didn't
think what though would get beat up or
knocked out but I knew that people gonna
see you on a different perception people
never seen with down this prime against
babalu when against Randy cold war
people had seen that I gotta watch that
fight and go that was back to high and I
just saw the pictures of him he looked
old he looked like he didn't belong in
them but he's doing with it why for
financial purposes nearly because the
UFC was paying them when William Morris
took over they cut his job as a
consultant at least two years he was
taking care of him and he could [ __ ]
survive it yeah I got you having to go
into the ring at how old he was at forty
seven forty no listen I don't give a
[ __ ] what everybody tells you after 40
you start seeing things that unless
you're realistic with yourself nobody
could help see hmm
okay your kicks don't lose a little bit
of snapped yeah your vision starts to
grow go you know relaxin
we action tire starts to go you think
you still have your original movement
put yourself on tape boy are you gonna
be disappointed
you know alright when I go to the gym I
know the more we tie class the mornings
I know exactly who I am
I know exactly how old I am I know what
my purpose is therefore do you follow me
you will see guys that go to the gym and
they just don't get it they've been
going there for nine months and also
though I shake put on your gloves and
you're like you really don't get it
but I didn't destroy you with my hands
you know people just don't see things
sometimes I'm happy that yeah you at
least took a step back yeah and they
were analyzing it you're analyzing it
definitely you know and someday you'll
maybe officially retire or someday you
might say [ __ ] it they offered me too
much money to go to Japan it's a
three-fight contract they haven't give
me a million dollars my family needs to
eat sure we all get pushed into that
direction of making that decision you
know right
I felt the noticeable I felt the
noticeable difference like thirty thirty
one right around there I know what yeah
I'm only 33 but I started a fight when I
was 20 so it's like I think about 31 I
could you kind of feel a little bit of a
difference
moreso reactions maybe not as sharp or
you know move is quickly you know I mean
takedowns not as fast but you know you
can notice that stuff but the problem
with the problem with the fight the
sport is people don't like to have that
realistic conversation with themselves
either you know they like to know I'm
good I'm good you know they like to
[ __ ] just act like it's not there but
gotta have that objective conversation
you know I mean who wants to tell
yourself that you don't not anybody
I can't imagine you know I mean
throughout my comedy career there was
moments when I was like you know what I
think really I want to get a day job at
one point and then you come back to your
senses you know you're like I'm not
ready to give up yet
this is happening on this happened but
again that's a complete different
situation than the fighting in the Tom
Brady search I don't want to see Tom
getting sacked yeah and now I don't want
to see Tom's back being broken because
he claimed move you know all it takes is
one guy missing a block which they have
the best offensive line in the world
yeah they really do well that was kind
of really [ __ ] do we have like a he's
like in his sixties or seventies maybe
even 80s offensive line coach he retired
for like two years of the guy who came
in kind of stunk cribs didn't do it they
didn't do as well so they took about a
retirement he's like 80 years old in
there yeah you gotta know who the best
is they don't my hat's go off the boat
team you see like the ramps to the
defensive line like they got some
[ __ ] kill it like Dom consuming you
know a few like a few killers on their
d-line so it's they got it and the
Patriots got a great line offensive line
but these guys are getting better off if
that's crazy our defense like our
defense is usually pretty good what's
our and you do not burn a cow I never
say the Patriots that saying like Bernie
County the fourth quarter was very
vexing the patriots defensive backs are
are okay usually but we usually have
like I'm not so great so I was surprised
because you guys have great quarterbacks
and like oh you're Kelsey's great
you know yeah you guys it why you
calling them you guys does he look like
a [ __ ] rest talking about sports
oh no don't keep saying you guys Jake
Ellenberger
right all right I'm sorry aren't you
happy you [ __ ] I didn't like the last
podcast with Jake dig that look too high
and I wanted to do Joey Diaz
[ __ ]
and we saw at Jake Ellenberger - yeah
and Jake Ellenberger thank you let
people know that don't mess around with
drugs understand me especially weed from
Joey Diaz and a bum you never know what
you're gonna it ain't it ain't the same
I didn't mean any malice I know I
thought you can handle it hell yeah I
heard you [ __ ] up till about 2:00 in
the morning
know what the yeah did you really take
it away oh yeah
Cartier I was like I can't drive I'm
[ __ ] I wouldn't eight that didn't do
nothing
no I was talking a kale like I are do
you know what time it is what day it is
I'm uber and no and when you woke up the
next morning how did you feel I was
[ __ ] still i yeah a little bit
I was still a little bit like what I
don't know there's a weed I had the the
the snippets like the the visual memory
like a little snip like kind of piecing
them back together but that's crazy
where do you go to eat I even know some
some joint down the street Mexican place
yeah
Mexico yeah they went yeah I know there
were like Lynn Taylor she said she goes
yeah he was nothing there's no stars he
just smoked that I gave me like 31% weed
yeah and you're a healthy guy you took a
big bong hit and they just kept creeping
on you like a finger they asked it just
kept getting deeper and deeper and I
would ask you questions and you were
like shrug them off thank God we have a
great great people listening to this
show and they love that [ __ ] yeah like
we [ __ ] up a couple people here and a
lot of them which stars you know we had
a that went up in the hospital we had we
had a girl who I had to put on the couch
George Perez I had to lay him down
Georgia the best was Owen Wolfson
ideally Owen Benjamin got up and walked
out and kept walking next time I talk to
him is I mentor and Vanna he's walking
around lost they moved to Vermont he
started using the n-word and they threw
him off Twitter oh [ __ ] or somebody sent
us a tape of him just you got me yeah
before we end this watch this live he
goes somebody sent us a a video a
youtube video of us with Owen Benjamin
this is what pushed him over the edge
the star death that pushed him over
yes the podcast has changed our Benjamin
wife oh Jesus Christ Li Sam supposed to
have this [ __ ] so they can see it who
could see it looking for watching all
right hit it we wait on flowers here the
Church of what's happening now the devil
was very to see you [ __ ] in the ass
lit on fire and drop off the Cosby's out
oh [ __ ] Oh get those shoes on [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] those moves [ __ ] oh my god
these stars are kicking in fact we're
not [ __ ] around easy I'm saying these
have been sitting at the dock Owen
Benjamin what's happen just the stars
are kicking in pretty high up yeah and I
wouldn't even let you the second one
because I know these things smack people
around really hard College so I was
always traveling so I never really
looked forward to more it's almost like
our job is people's party so it's like
you don't live in the frat house you
know you kind of just go Owen Benjamin
just gave me a look that I recognize
it's a look that's telling me crazy I
yes let's hit yeah yeah I'm sorry
no but it's cool like all your story
what water because you're such a
descriptive talker that everything
you're saying I'm like literally seeing
in my head it's really fun
Hollywood feeling all right yeah I'm
John gets a man yeah now I'm [ __ ]
crazy I know okay young world water yeah
okay let's do some water yeah [ __ ] I
told you you want to leave - I saved
because I like that
oh that his voice changed a little bit
and I know he stays in a lot more
it's tremendous yellow stains is strong
you just relax
this is the double here tonight handle
six because we're training on Benjamin
Benjamin coming back this is good [ __ ]
these stars the stars at that power
Benjamin yeah you wanna take a walk
you're right get some air right get some
eye on the black water with you just in
case you [ __ ] you know you want to be
hydrate a little bit you'll be alright
this happens is they have to do a
thousand things little stupid is the
real deal the church you know there's a
matter of fact I'm gonna bag them
another one other respect for you people
you know I love you all my heart I hope
you have a good week I mean this Donnell
[ __ ] solo dick just to let you know
we ain't [ __ ] around no more
take your [ __ ] leave I got time for
this [ __ ] no more your attitude should
be like my attitude it's over
we're taking over this [ __ ] right or
wrong [ __ ]
I really think on Benjamin abandoned
ship he's the first guest that has ever
a baby I don't know I think he's out I
could see it there was one point where I
could see his eye just go yeah he would
have been dead I want to thank on
Benjamin these stars of [ __ ] brutal
[Laughter]
tweet that out though to eat that I
suppose it let's say composure yeah okay
so what do you think about I see you
shouldn't feel that bad at least you sat
through it like a man you Jake
Ellenberger out of Omaha Nebraska and
some hits I'm taking some punches oh my
god that was Chinese well we shouldn't
pull a [ __ ] hold Benjamin Mee you
said you took about your [ __ ] man now
you're back he never came back
he just kept going this family up and
they were out of here they moved to
Beverly Hills like the belly Hill I
don't know where he went anyway keep us
posted what's the name of your company
with that though the role you gave me an
overall race you hyper race you have a
web page tweeters too high price comm
it's great that role I love it even if
nothing love that bra I love it
it saves my life it really does man but
I wish you the best of luck your family
whenever you want to come on the [ __ ]
podcast thank you
I'm sorry about [ __ ] [ __ ] in your last
time now I don't really horrible now you
can trace that I didn't [ __ ] use just
regular [ __ ] strong yeah and let you
[ __ ] know I don't [ __ ] around
so if you come by the Voodoo Lounge you
- I'm gonna get zapped
I'm gonna have to tell a bunch of people
yeah [ __ ] it we don't [ __ ] around here
for a while
no are you hung it out like a man
appreciation so thank you very much
you're always family you're always
welcome on the show I want to thank you
guys for listen don't forget Thursday
night Brea it's gonna be a [ __ ] on
and then Friday night that's all that's
available it's Thursday and Friday
Saturday sold out so get your
[ __ ] tickets
don't forget Valentine's Day and San
Jose Valentine's Day in San Jose what
are you [ __ ] nuts or what all right I
want to thank my main man Jake
Ellenberger - the first time we had
technical difficulties there was a
malfunction I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most of all I want to
thank you guys but before we leave I
want to talk to you about something
there
listen how much longer can you stand
online the postal office you know you
want your new year's resolution that you
can actually keep stop wasting your time
by going to the post office and you
could send letters and packages right
from your desk do it today with stamps
calm me my wife that's all we use and
we've been using them for years why
because they bring the postal US Postal
Service right to you use your computer
to print official US postage so any
letter or any size package going
anywhere in the world and the best part
is the mailman will pick it up right in
front of house no more lugging boxes to
the post office
stamps comm is also going to save you
money by giving you a discounted rate on
stamps that you can't even get at the
post office
you're never gonna pay full price for
stamps again and their postage meters
are a fraction of the cost plus you
don't have to sign a lease and there's
no long term commitment if you're
leaving money on the table if you don't
sign up that's what you're doing you're
leaving money on the table if you don't
sign up so do me a favor I use stamps
com personally my wife cuz it's a
no-brainer
saves me time and money right now they
got a special offer for we trial plus
postage and the digital scale to start
the new year right get your trial today
you own the business you're starting a
new business a small business doesn't
matter
Stan's calm is the way to go go to
Stan's calm right now do me a favor grab
the pen and click the microphone at the
top of the homepage and use the promo
code Church why go to Stan's calm and
enter church and start sending your mail
like a doctor with stamps.com another
business that I love I love for small
business I love a business business's
zip recruit or why because it's a
smarter way to go you know what's not
smart job boards that make you wait for
the right people to apply for your job
you know it's not smart job words that
assume qualified candidates will see and
apply to your job post with this let me
tell you something this is the best and
quickest way to hire or again I'm 56 I
got one foot in the grave one a banana
peel and I believe in saving time and
working smart there
CUDA is working smart unlike other job
sites zip recruiter finds the qualified
candidates for you
it's a powerful matching technology that
scans through thousands of resumes to
identify the people with the right
skills education and experience and it
actively invites them to apply to your
job so you get the qualified candidates
fast that's it you don't got to go
through a bunch of bumps that's why zip
recruiter is rated number one by
employers all in the US this rating
comes from hiring sites on trust pilot
with over a thousand reviews so right
now what we're gonna do is this all
right the church family you can try out
zip recruiter for ready for this free
free you can try it out for free I don't
care whether you have a small
landscaping business here looking for a
designer oh I don't care if you have a
huge company I'm gonna give you 0
crooner for free go to zip recruiter
comm slash Church if you like the show
you want to show a little support again
this is gonna help your business why not
give it a shot
go to zip recruiter dot-com slash Joey
again Church CH you are CH that zip
recruiter comm slash Joey zip recruiter
is a smarter way to hire I want to thank
the zip recruiter and I want to thank
dance comm for supporting us this week
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys for being the best family we could
have you know and I know least too high
right now too handsome but he just nod
his head like a [ __ ] moment listen
you guys are the goods and I love you
don't forget Thursday and Friday night
bread couple tickets left
February 14th San Jose the San Jose
improv and most important Treasure
Island the 22nd and the Fox Theatre in
Tucson on the 23rd I love you guys with
all my heart I will see you Thursday
morning tip top to Magoo ready to
[ __ ] go check this [ __ ] melee